in the last video we got as far as
figuring out the area of this coach
snowflake this thing that has an
infinite perimeter can be expressed as
this as this infinite sum right over
here and so our job in this video is to
try to simplify this and hopefully get a
finite value so let's do our best to
actually simplify this thing right over
here so the easiest part of this thing
to simplify is this right over here so
let's just focus on that and then if we
can get a value for this part that i'm
bracketing off then we can just place
that value here and then simplify the
rest of it so what i've just bracketed
about what i've just bracketed off can
be rewritten as 3 times
4 9 3 times 4 9 plus
4 9 squared
4 9 squared plus 4 9 to the third power
3 to the third power
third power and you can go on and on and
on i'll plus 4 9's to every other power
all the way through through infinity
and lucky for us there is a way to
figure out this infinite what is called
a geometric series there's a way to
figure this out and there's a we do
videos actually i think i've done
several videos where we proved the
general thing but i'll just do it by
hand this time just so that we don't
have to resort to some magical formulas
so let's say that we define some sum
let's say that we say this sum right
over here let's call that s
so i'm going to say that s
s is equal to what we have in
parentheses right over here it's going
to be equal to
4 9
plus
4 9 squared plus 4 9 to the third power
4 nice to the third power all the way to
infinity
now let's also say that let's multiply s
times 4 9. let me write that down here
so if we multiply s times 4 9 let me
give myself some space here so what's 4
9 s going to look like so 4 9 s
so then i'm just essentially multiplying
every term here times 4 9. so if i take
this first term and multiply it times 4
9 what am i going to get well i'm going
to get 4 9 squared
4 9 squared if i take the second term
and multiply it times 4 9 i'm going to
get
i'm going to get 4 9
to the third power and we're going to go
all the way to infinity so this is
interesting when i multiply 4 nice times
s i get all of the terms here except for
this first four ninths and now this is
kind of the magic of how we can actually
find the sum of an infinite an infinite
geometric series is we can subtract
this term right over here we can
subtract this pink line from this green
line
so if we do that
if we do that clearly this is equal to
that and that is equal to that so if we
subtract this from that it's equivalent
to subtracting the pink from the green
so we get s minus 4 9. sorry s minus 4 9
s
minus 4 let me do that in that pink
color just so we know what we're doing
minus 4 9 s
is equal to
well every other term this guy minus
this guy is going to cancel out this guy
minus this guy is going to cancel out
and that's going to happen all the way
all the way to infinity and on the right
hand side you're only going to be left
with you're only going to be left with
this 4 9 right over here
only going to be left with this 4 9 and
then this 4 9 we can
s is the same thing as 9 over 9
so we could write this as 9 over 9 s
minus 4 9 s is equal to 4 9. and so 9
over 9 minus 4 over 9 of something gives
us 5 over 9 so this becomes 5
9 s
is equal to 4 9 and then to solve for s
and this is kind of magical but it's
actually quite logical multiply both
sides times the inverse of this so times
9 fifths so that we can isolate the s
times nine fifths
these guys cancel out and we get s is
equal to four fifths
s is equal to four fifths that's really
this is this is kind of neat this whole
thing right over here we have just shown
to ourselves is equal to four-fifths
is equal to four-fifths so this entire
bracket that we did right over here is
equal to three times four-fifths so this
entire bracket right over here is equal
to three times 4 fifths or it's equal to
12
it's equal to 12 over 5 that entire
bracket so now let's go to our original
expression just so we don't lose track
of what we're doing
we have the square root of 3
square root of 3 s squared over 16
and then we have this 4 here
4
plus
this whole thing this whole thing right
over here simplified to 12 fifths
plus 12
plus twelve fifths
now just to add these two things we can
rewrite four is twenty-fifths
we can rewrite this as twenty we can
rewrite this as twenty over five and
then twenty over five plus twelve over
five is 32 over 5.
so let me write this down right over
here so this whole thing right over here
is going to be 32
32 over 5. and this is really the home
stretch now this is very exciting we're
about to find the finite area of
something that has an infinite perimeter
so it's going to be let me rewrite it
just i don't want to get messy in all of
the excitement here square root of 3 s
squared over 16
times 32 over 5 times 32
over 5. and 32 we can divide both the
numerator and the denominator by 16. 32
divided by 16 is 2 16 divided by 16 is 1
and we are left with and this is where
we really do need a drum roll the area
of a of a coach snowflake where the
initial equilateral triangle that we
started with has each of its sides is
length s and they're all length s
because an equilateral triangle is i'll
do this in magenta square root was going
to be 2 times the square root of 3
2 times the square root of 3
s squared so whatever that side length
was
all of that over let's see we use the 2
we use the square root of 3 we use the s
squared all of that over
all of that over 5. so for example if
that first equilateral triangle if that
first equilateral triangle we started
out with had a side length of 1 then the
area of this crazy thing that has an
infinite perimeter would just be 2
square roots of 3 times 1 squared over 5
or 2 squares to 3
over 5. anyway i think that's that's
kind of kind of cool